on sunday the mets got javier baez back
in the lineup today after missing 37
games francisco lindor is back from an
oblique injury and lindor will get to
play shortstop next to his buddy javier
baez it should be a dynamic double play
combination well you look at tyler
mcgill's toyota numbers so far this year
we know he got off to that
rollicking start in his first seven
starts era just a smidge over two it's
been a struggle in august so now brandon
bell comes up for his first at-bat of
the night he was hit for so much power
felt hits that one to center field nimmo
all the way back and he's going to watch
it it is gone off the apple
18th of the year for granite belt i
don't think they're gonna bring that
apple up out of its little holster
for a giants home run but that one
431 feet it's one-nothing giants
sammy long making that start got that
quick out
see the numbers there not overall not
pretty but the left-handed batting
average against you see under 100 able
to just devastate left-handed batters
curveball got him swinging that's a
beauty
fastball and he hits that one to left
carrying pretty well dickerson all the
way back in front of 358 and he'll make
the catch nice ovation for wilmer flores
back in new york and he goes after the
first pitch and drives one down the
right field line toward the corner that
is a fair ball conforto will play the
karum wilmer flores zen to second with a
slide
welcome back to the big city
meanwhile mike kustremski you had his
birthday yesterday on the off day
19 home runs for yaz
fastball ella was hit well to right
center field mike yastremski can watch
it it's gone
and by plenty
a two-run homer his 20th of the year
three-nothing giants
451.
just another great at-bat by another
left-handed hitter
and vice draws a walk 3-2 curveball
couldn't get him to chase
so the vets have their first base runner
of the night
fastball on the ground crawford kind of
an awkward play but he got the out at
second to throw in time double play
this time that's not a home run but
guess what to base it and it sounded
like it broke his home run back
just a six to four to three randomly
yeah dickerson on the ground to first
alonzo and nobody came to cover mcgill
wasn't there alonso bobbled it
and tyler mcgill cost himself an out
giants will take it with first and third
and one out and crawford goes down
swinging for a second time
mcgill got him with the fastball again
and that's the second out
and wilmer goes down swinging
and mcgill despite his fielding mistake
finds his way out of trouble long winds
here it comes
curveball straight three caught on the
outside corner at the knees
those 16 games will at least give them a
chance to fatten up and give themselves
a chance
mcgill lines one to right and wing can't
get it
mcgill on his way to second
he lumbers in and he's not going to go
any farther
the mets first tent of the night is a
double for tylor mcgill his second big
league extra basin
made me wonder what's going on that's
into center base head
lamont wade junior who was lined out to
center then he hit a fly ball to center
this next
time deep center nimmo going back still
going back adios
pelota
i thought
oh yeah that's gone that
it is five to nothing giants
just over the 408 side and just over the
glove
of nemo
and it shot right back onto the field
the jad's third home run of the game
belt hit one way over that 408 marker
and into the big apple housing his first
time
belt
deep left
and
that ball is gone an opposite field home
run from brandon belt
is the ball flying here or what
second home run of the game for bell
and belt and wade
go
back to back
six to nothing giants
buster and that will get down bay's head
to left field
[Applause]
that ball is knocked down by alonso and
then
baez trying to bare hand it couldn't
come up with it
and everybody is safe and they might
have been even if he had come up with it
and it's right-hander trevor williams
coming on you see he's making a bunch of
starts he started with the cubs this
year came on over kind of trying to find
his way in this reliever role trevor
williams takes over against brandon
crawford two on two out three runs in
for the giants in the fourth chance for
more 11 hits in three and two third
innings against mcgill
crawford base hit the right center
coming around third posey lotus waves
him home he scores over to third base
ghost dickerson brandon crawford with
the two out rbi single seven to nothing
giants
the one two
a curve for strike three called
mcneal slaps one tough play for crawford
running to his right and he can't throw
him out
mazeka
shallow left field
and crawford wants to take charge and he
does
sammy long signed with his hometown
giants 2-2
this is lined towards shallow left
dickerson got a late start comes in now
won't get there to base it brandon nemo
with a little dunk shot to shallow left
field jay jackson the former hiroshima
tayo carp and chiba latte marine
poked the other way and he got on that
slider for a base hit nice job by alonso
two on two out bottom six one one pitch
pulled on the ground to third wilmer's
got it he'll flip to second for the
fourth down on the door
just a little dribbler not gonna be an
easy play davis has got the big arm but
not in time now breaking for third
mazika covering ruff gets in there
pretty good hustle from darren ruff
chance for some brandon belt history
tonight
that's not a home run but it is a tough
play lindor not in time wade got there
baez thinks
his foot was on the bag ahead of the
slide no matter what daryn ruff comes in
to score it's eight nothing belt's going
to get a run batted in
and pete takes another one to right
field
he could do that in his sleep couldn't
he
oh he's hitting the helmet oh my god is
awful i think it glanced
the sound of plastic
excruciating
gets it right up and goes to first base
three and one to mcneal
on the ground the first branded belts
got it he'll ditch to chatwood for the
final out of the ball game of the giants
finish off the shutout
[Applause]